بالنظر إلى هذا ، قد ترى رئيسًا
يرمي قبعات رائعة لـ Keep America ، لكن
ربما يرى الرئيس ترامب لاعبًا
أولمبيًا يونانيًا يلقي قرصًا بعد كل ما
نشره على تويتر بهذه الصورة المزيفة
لرأسه المرفقة
بجذع روكي بالبوا المحفور ، ها هي الصورة الأصلية
بدلاً من فعلها.  الاعتصامات أو ضخ الحديد
يميل الرئيس ترامب إلى ضخ
قبضتي النقاد ، ويقارنوا
الرئيس بهومر سيمبسون وهو
يتفحص تفكيره ويتخيل صدمات لا تشوبها شائبة
وكأنني أنظر في المرآة ورأيت
هذا يزعجني ،
فلا يوجد شيء مثل
فوتوشوب رئاسي يلهمني.  أطنان
من متاجر الصور غير المألوفة عندما
تطلب شيئًا عبر الإنترنت مقابل عندما
تصل إلى الإدراك مقابل الواقع ، فأنت
متوهم. نكتة دون جونيور نجل الرئيس
سمعت من مصادر
موثوقة أنه لم يتم التلاعب بالكلب السلكي اليومي الذي قام
بالتلاعب بالصورة التي تم التلاعب بها بالفعل
عن طريق إضافة  كونان البطل كلب
الرئيس في الوقت الحالي يبدو أن
صدره على دماغه وآخر
حشد له هو  انتقدوا الصحافة
لقولهم المزعوم أنه أصيب بنوبة
قلبية عندما ذهب إلى مستشفى والتر ريد
في اليوم الآخر قالوا إنه
لم يكن يرتدي زهرًا إذا كان أول شيء
يفعلونه هو خلع قميصك يا سيدي
وإظهار ذلك لنا  صدر رائع ذلك الصندوق
الرائع لرجل قال لرويترز ذات مرة
إنني أمارس الرياضة ، أعني أنني أمشي
أنا هذا ، هذا الجذع المزيف لترامب تمت
مقارنته بصدره الحقيقي العاري بوتين
الذي كان يرتديه بشكل أفضل ،
فركه بعض النقاد في علامة التصنيف ،
لم يكن أوباما بحاجة إلى رئيس Photoshop.
غرد السكرتير الصحفي السابق لكلينتون
الآن ونحن نعلم ما فعلوه به في
والتر ريد في هذه الحالة أريد ما
كان لديه
تشيني زميل
نيويورك
[موسيقى]